il ya une redistribution des cartes
géopolitiques majeurs et ça pose la
question de l'otan sur tout le temps
qu'a été abordé d'ailleurs dans le débat
zemmour mélenchon en disant mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait encore là dedans à quoi ça
sert aujourd'hui sachant que les
américains les états unis sont
maintenant omnubilé par la puissance
chinoise par le pacifique et que
l'europe est devenue simplement un sous
terrain de jeu mais qui n'a plus rien à
voir avec l'europe du rideau de fer
l'adaptation avec l'urss oui mais on
sait qu'il ya quand même une
confrontation à bas bruit avec la russie
que c'est à ça que sert l'otan en europe
en grande partie aux américains et que
tous les pays de l'est de l'europe sont
à juste titre historiquement angoissés
par la rue cif et c'est à ça que ça sert
comme boucliers à l'est sur leurs ailes
est mes éléments clés sur la baltique
oui c'est ça mais c'est certain que le
premier ennemi des états unis n'est pas
la russie ou le vin c'est pas elle qui a
les moyens d'être en tout cas c'est la
chine et je pense qu'on assiste aussi un
gros déploiement des puissances
maritimes en fait depuis pendant
longtemps vous avez cette théorie qui a
prévalu le ch et les géopoliticiens on
savait qu il faut c est l hinterland
c'est à dire que pour les américains il
faut jamais que le continent
eurasiatique soient rassemblés il faut
qu'ils contrôlent eux mêmes les
américains le milieu pour casser ce
continent rien ce qui était le cas en
afghanistan ce qui était le cas en irak
ils ont peur en fait d'être marginalisés
si ça arrive aujourd'hui de leurs
blessures mais je pense qu'il s'en fiche
un petit peu de cg parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un gros déploiement plutôt
maritime on a des talos oak racing en
fait qu'elles sont le royaume uni
l'australie les etats-unis en fait qui
se déploie autour de la chine pour la
circonscrire et c'est là que va se jouer
si on veut dire le sort du monde dans
les années qui viennent